joining us in the studio is Professor
Tim and spoon of the German Aerospace
Center he's an expert on the conditions
of on other planets a planetary
scientists welcome to our show
what do you think will we ever find a
form of life on Mars I certainly hope so
although I can't be certain
unfortunately the reason being the
finding life expecting life is one thing
but finding it is another and it could
be like the search of a needle in the
haystack but maybe the occurrence of
life is just such a rare event in our
world that it happened all the ones here
on earth that is possible although I
wouldn't consider that very likely
because although I mean we have special
conditions on this planet you know if
you consider and the expected number of
planets in the universe we would just
conclude that there must be other
planets that would Harbor some form of
life how many planets are out there
we're asking about ten to twenty four
planets I mean they have one with 25
zeros this is a lot and what sort of
life would you expect is that a highly
developed life something like us humans
are just green slime
well we couldn't exclude higher develop
life-forms although those are even less
likely than you know I mean then life
may be out by itself but microbes is
certainly your best bet and then there
may be places out there or even life has
develop maybe not as much as on earth
but further than be just a mere curb you
in life-forms so you think we're still
the top of evolution or are there aliens
actually to top us maybe the maybe then
maybe aliens that are even more evolved
you know than we are but that is of
course entirely speculative we don't
know but you know from the likelihood I
mean there is no reason to believe that
you know humans on earth are the most
evolved life form in the universe this
is not there's no reason to do that
maybe there is just a completely
different form
of life maybe nature's is a lot more
fanciful than we could be we don't know
how genius evolution could be but you
know I I think you know the baby are
made I mean is is you know something
that no has sense I mean we have our two
eyes because we need to touch distances
we have our arns to grab things and it's
very likely that evolution of the places
find similar tools but it may be they
look like us maybe well we also say that
life always depends on water
could you imagine a different situation
without one well people talk about
replacing water in other environments
where it is colder with fluids that
would be fluid at lower temperatures
than then on earth this could be
hydrocarbons for instance on Titan we
could expect that versus Saturn which is
a moon of Saturn yeah but we actually
have a chance to recognize these
different types of life well this is a
good question you know I I think you
could say I recognize it when I see it
but there is no accepted definition in
the insides what life actually is we're
still lacking that thanks a lot for the
top office I take much more